hey what is up everybody it's animac
here for anime uproar and the Shonen
side of the internet just exploded as
Black Clover unveiled what could be its
most controversial chapter ever people
are already freaking out and calling
Black Clover Disney Clover they're
saying Tabitha went too far with this
latest reveal and they're saying this
might be the end of Black Clover so is
this the end is the fandom going to
destroy itself from the inside are we at
least gonna get some good memes out of
this let's break it all down and then
you can decide for yourself you guys
know the drill if you enjoy our Black
Clover videos and you want to see more
in the future leave a quick like and
comment right now it only takes you a
second but it helps me out with that
YouTube algorithm and if you don't know
over half of all the people who watch
our videos are not actually subscribed
if you are one of those people please
subscribe right now and hit that
notification Bell to turn on all
notifications subscribing on YouTube is
completely free but it's a very real way
of directly supporting the channel and
it means a lot finally this video will
contain Black Clover manga spoilers so
please proceed with caution you have
been warned
the final battle in Black Clover the
battle for the Clover Kingdom capital
that is being waged between Lucius and
his paladins on the one side and the
strongest magic knights in the Clover
Kingdom on the other side really
intensified during the last chapter as
you know took Center Stage yuno
demonstrated wizard King levels of power
as he created a gigantic star magic
portal over the entire capital and he
used it to save the whole city from a
massive enemy attack in that moment
Lucius identified yuno as a serious
threat to his master plan and he vowed
to destroy yuno right here and now the
latest chapter declares that the fate of
the Clover Kingdom rests in yuno's hands
as yuno and Lucius prepare to do battle
Lucius acknowledges that yuno is strong
but he's not strong enough to prevent
Judgment Day as the two of them are
facing off those Angelic figures that
are floating above the capital are
attacked by the polar Kingdom Mages now
these guys are not paladins they seem to
be just like NPCs who look like a cross
between angels and mummies however
despite using multiple magic attributes
and extremely powerful magic attacks the
Mages of the Clover Kingdom just can't
seem to damage these Angel things Morris
implies that these creatures used to be
humans who rebelled against Lucius and
they were eventually transformed into
the guardian angels of the new world
they used to be Renegades and Rebels and
now they are the Bringers of Law and
Order if this is true then it is
extremely creepy these NPCs apparently
used to be humans whom Lucius deemed to
be inferior and Unworthy of his new
world and so he turned them into
essentially mindless zombies of
Destruction but the main point regarding
these angels is that even though they
appear to be mindless NPCs that just
carry out lucius's will they are still
impossibly strong and even multiple
powerful black hover Mages working
together can't seem to make any Headway
against them overall the situation seems
pretty hopeless and yet the Clover
Kingdom Knights know that they have to
fight to protect their people even if
that means certain death as one of the
Angels launches a light beam attack like
the one we saw in the previous chapter
Seoul tries to stop it with one of her
giant Golems she actually thinks that
her attack will likely fail and she
fully expects to die within seconds but
to her surprise her Golem actually
manages to stop the Angels attack it is
as if her magic suddenly became way
stronger than it had been before and it
is in this moment that we learn why the
wind spirit self is also known as Belle
bell bell reveals a new overpowered
spell that she and yuno have developed a
spell that is apparently the reflection
of their love now I don't know if this
is just a one-sided love from Belle's
perspective or if yuno is also in love
with her too now after the time skip but
I will say that her character has really
developed since the beginning of the
story if you know what I mean so who
knows maybe Tabata really is setting up
a romance between the two of them anyway
the spell is a combination of star and
wind spirit magic called manazone
Neverland
this spell allows yuno and Belle to
manipulate the flow of magic power
inside this specific space a space that
seems to Encompass the entire Clover
Kingdom capital within this space the
magic of yuno and Belle's allies is
strengthened while the magic of their
enemies is weakened and so all the
Clover Kingdom Mages are now going to be
stronger and all of lucius's
subordinates are now going to be weaker
than they were before I mean we always
knew that self AKA Bell was inspired by
Tinkerbell from Peter Pan but it seems
that the Peter Pan references are going
to extend far beyond just that Neverland
is of course an imaginary Fantasy Island
where Peter Pan and Tinkerbell live in
the Peter Pan story along with other
characters like Captain Hook Tiger Lily
and the Lost Boys one prominent feature
of Neverland is the fact that its
inhabitants never seem to age as if time
stands still although in some versions
Peter Pan is the only one who doesn't
age because he refuses to grow up but
the other characters still do then yet
another person declares that yuno is now
at the level of a wizard King this time
it's Klaus Lunette of the Golden Dawn in
the very next moment the Clover Kingdom
Mages Advance on the angels and attack
them with everything they've got but as
all of this is happening Lucius suddenly
appears behind you know and traps him
within one of his time spheres Lucius
Smiles knowing that he will now be able
to destroy you know by accelerating his
aging but for some reason nothing
happens to yuno it turns out that yuno's
Neverland spell is very similar to Peter
Pan's Neverland because inside of it
time doesn't move and so yuno will not
age even if a Time magic spell is used
on him Lucius realizes that this really
is the type of magic that was born to
oppose him and he hates it he proclaims
you know to be his real rival but you
know doesn't return the favor yunos says
that Lucius is not his real rival
because we all know that his true rival
is our boy Asta and the chapter ends as
yuno uses his Spirit of zephyr's Sword
to cut through Lucius now we can't tell
how much damage yuno actually does to
Lucius because the chapter ends at the
point that yuno's sword makes contact
with the villain but it's safe to assume
that Lucius isn't going anywhere anytime
soon that said how crazy is Neverland
and is it too broken I mean to be fair
Lucius is broken too but such a drastic
power-up for yuno kinda smashes
everything we thought we knew about the
Black Clover power system this 18 year
old guy is so powerful that he can make
portals the size of the capital city he
can create a space that is also the size
of the entire capital city where all his
allies become stronger and all his
enemies become weaker and where time
magic has no effect on him like that is
absolutely insane and it makes the power
of the wizard King Julius look pretty
basic in comparison and that brings me
to the main controversy of this chapter
many believe that Tabata and black over
went too far and they turned yuno into a
Disney character they turned him into an
overpowered Peter Pan who seems to have
everything going for him he has Noble
blood he has leaked sun inside out of
him he has the wind spirit he is both
wind and star magic and he is able to
get so strong so fast even though the
magic Knight captains can't even come
close to comparing to him so a lot of
people are mad because they feel that
you know is the opposite of an underdog
the man has every possible Advantage he
won the magical Lottery and his broken
Powers cheap in the world and the power
system of Black Clover after all what is
the combination of wind and star magic
have to do with stopping time does it
even make sense now I am not one to shy
away from a fair critique and Black
Clover certainly can be critiqued the
fact that almost no one dies and people
who are dead just resurrect does take
away from the tension during a big
battle because at this point you just
don't expect anyone important to
actually die at least not permanently I
can also understand that people are
worried about power creep and Black
Clover and yuno's new powers are a
perfect example of that but at the same
time Black Clover is in its final Arc
this is probably the final battle so if
Tabata is ever going to go all out with
the crazy powers and power-ups now would
be the time and yeah I do agree that
yuno is really broken right now and yes
the man turned out to be extremely
fortunate to inherit such rare Magic and
elf Powers oh and he just happens to be
a spade Kingdom Royal and so on if you
know really where to take down Lucius I
would completely agree that Tabata went
too far but I do want to see where
things go because Lucius is also
extremely overpowered like the man
literally has the powers of a Creator
God so I don't think that yuno will be
able to defeat him despite his new
power-ups I still think that yuno will
need the help of Asta and everyone else
in the Clover Kingdom in order to take
Lucius down and the final battle will
likely include some really intense
twists and turns and some incredible
teamwork don't get me wrong I don't
think we're going to get any sort of
crazy twist or where Lucius actually
wins in the end or where some important
character dies but I do think that the
final battle will be worth following and
I think that the ultimate result of the
battle will feel earned I could be wrong
and Tabata might really be going off the
rails like some people are claiming and
like the power system may just become
irrelevant as yuno and Austin Lucius get
super strong and leave everyone else in
the dust but I am hopeful that important
aspects of black hole are battles like
teamwork and suspense and strategy will
play an essential role in the end what
do you guys think you're here watching a
black hole video so you definitely
follow the series and you certainly have
an opinion on this did this chapter go
too far did it break the power system of
Black Clover and did it turn yuno into a
Mary Sue or I guess a Gary stew does
Tabata know what he's doing with the
ending or are we going to get Disney
Clover power of friendship talk no Jutsu
fancy world breaking power-ups that
don't really make sense based on what
we've seen so far and so on definitely
leave your feedback down in the comments
below there's been a lot of controversy
over this chapter and I really want to
know what the community thinks if you
enjoyed this video and you want to see
more Black Clover content in the future
leave a quick like and comment right now
and if you're one of the over 50 of
people who watch our videos but still
haven't taken the time to subscribe do
me a big favor and make this the video
that you subscribe and hit that
notification Bell to turn on all
notifications you can also hit me up on
Twitter and Instagram at
anime uproar as always thank you guys so
much for watching and until next time
see ya Space Cowboys